Delaware healthcare protocol for
marketing so I mean you know some of the
target physicians Foster's facilities
like and what are you trying to sell
them your well it's our service you know
we do a lot of our management for them
yep but then now we're also growing at
Jessie okay all the products to like
with networking and all that stuff and
so so think about it backwards
think about everything in articles why
physicians why hospitals need to start
caring about privacy mm-hmm and then
write that article why independent
physicians need to understand snapchat
and write that article that's how I
reverse engineer once you start with
what you think they should be thinking
about like whatever your IT you're
selling there's a why there's a why you
think they should have it right you know
like people of lions don't be the doctor
that loses your patients data yeah
article then that article or video is
deployed against physicians on LinkedIn
against physicians on Facebook
understand yes but see what I'm afraid
of with with Facebook is because the
physicians yes who says well that's your
focus group of five or fifty is too
small you don't think dr. jeong's on
[ __ ] Facebook
all my positions are on Facebook I have
three they're all there I see their
[ __ ] pictures they're there as John
not as Doctor John doesn't mean John
doesn't see the video and if John sees
why physicians that start worrying about
data John might need that when he's
having his coffee on Tuesday morning
that's the problem people make decisions
on their focus group musically is gonna
be big people sameen email
well my 14 year old daughter says it's
not cool anymore Mazel Tov but your 14
old daughters not [ __ ] every
fourteen-year-old in America so the data
shows that plenty of doctors are on
Facebook probably most of them thank you
got it